in deutschland bestimmen diese zahlen
wies hier während der pandemie
weitergeht ob deutschland zurück in den
lockt da muss oder eben nicht es sind
die infektionszahlen aber wie wichtig
sind diese zahlen tatsächlich und sollte
man nur an ihnen fest machen wie wir
unser leben jetzt in pandemie zeiten
hier führen können genau darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit meinem kollegen
bild reporter philipp iad oft gerade bei
mir
philipp wie wichtig sind die krone
infektionszahlen die wir jetzt
eigentlich jeden tag bekommen also die
korona infektionszahlen sind sehr
wichtiger indikator dafür wie dynamisch
die pandemie jetzt gerade ist sie sind
ein guter frühindikator man möchte
nämlich wissen wie viele menschen
infizieren sich jetzt um nicht erst in
einigen wochen zum ersten zu spät zu
merken
aha jetzt sterben zu viele menschen die
intensivstationen werden zu voll
aber sind sie dürften nicht der einzige
indikator sein und wenn man sich mal
anschaut wie die bundesregierung
kommuniziert wenn man sich anschaut was
zum beispiel im letzten beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz stand da
sieht man dass der fokus extrem auf die
infektionszahlen gelegt wird und andere
kennziffern die auch sehr wichtig sind
bislang sehr vernachlässigt werden weil
die anderen kennziffern wollen wir
gleich sprechen aber vorher einmal ganz
kurz noch einmal schauen in unserem
politik talk die richtigen fragen der
gestern abend hier mit ihren sparen lief
und auch er hat sich natürlich zu den
aktuellen infektionszahlen geäußert die
frage ist ja ob sie im märz die gleiche
einschätzung gehabt hätten erstens und
zweitens man am ende ich meine wenn sie
so so so sagen 0,16 prozent oder 0,6
prozent sterblichkeit ist wenn sie das
mal auf eine million rechner und
einwohner oder oder betroffene ein
ziemlicher unterschied also das klingt
nach ganz wenig ist aber für die frage
wie eine krankheit einzuschätzen ist auf
eine gesamtbevölkerung eine ziemlich
großer unterschied
deswegen bin ich ja sehr dabei hermel es
geht darum die dinge einzuordnen und
miteinander abzuwägen und daraus
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
die dinge einzuordnen und abzuwägen was
ist gerade schon angesprochen
dafür sind aber auch andere zahlen
wichtig und welche genau geht es da
genau also ist lohnt sich immer auf
zahlen zu schauen die wirklich die harte
währung in der pandemie sind bei
infektionszahlen muss man nämlich dazu
sagen die werden auch dadurch getrieben
das schlichtweg mehr getestet wird ja
wir hatten jetzt einen leichten anstieg
der infektionszahlen der lag aber unter
anderem daran dass die test kapazitäten
innerhalb weniger wochen wirklich mehr
als verdoppelt wurden also mittlerweile
werden 1,1 millionen tests pro woche
durchgeführt
eine andere zahl die sehr wichtig ist
ist zum beispiel die anzahl der belegten
intensivbetten also wie viele menschen
in deutschland werden
intensivmedizinisch behandelt das waren
zeitweise um die 3000 menschen
mittlerweile sind wir seit vielen wochen
zum glück bei circa 220 230 und obwohl
wir diesen anstieg der infektionszahlen
hatten ist die zahl der intensiv mit der
belegten intensivbetten so koma
patienten behandelt werden dies zum
glück stabil geblieben
ein anderer faktor sind die todeszahlen
da sind wir gerade die kurve schon
gesehen wie vielleicht uns noch einmal
genauer dann angucken können als eine
der wichtigen zahlen denn natürlich von
anfang an war die angst groß dass eben
viele menschen in deutschland sterben
wie es da also die entwicklung ja also
im frühjahr hatten wir einen sehr
starken anstieg der der korona toten
das rkw vermeldete pro woche zum teil
über 2000 tote so hoch ist es zum glück
nicht mehr wir sind sehr sehr weit davon
entfernt wir sind ca zwischen 20 30 40
toten pro woche und auch hier muss man
sagen es gab keinen messbaren anstieg
obwohl die infektionszahlen hoch
gegangen sind
das heißt wenn man dabei ist von einer
zweiten welle zu sprechen was ja
zeitweise passiert ist darf man nicht
aus dem aus dem blick verlieren dass zum
glück die krankheitsverläufe
mittlerweile deutlich milder sind darum
gibt uns auch die hospitalisierung rate
auskunft also die rate die sagt wie hoch
der anteil der menschen der wegen corona
ins krankenhaus eingeliefert werden muss
und auch diese rate ist von 20 prozent
zum teil über 20 prozent im frühjahr auf
mittlerweile vier bis fünf prozent
gefallen das liegt unter anderem daran
dass ich mehr also dass der anteil der
jungen menschen die sich infizieren
höher ist und natürlich auch daran dass
die risikogruppen jetzt besser geschützt
sind und es gibt die positive rate die
positiv rate gibt darüber auskunft wie
hoch der anteil der positiv getesteten
ist unter allen getesteten auch dieser
anteil war zwischenzeitlich sehr hoch
mittlerweile ist er bei circa 0,7 0,8
prozent das heißt nicht einmal jeder
hundertste der getestet wird hat
tatsächlich positiven corona test wenn
diese zahl wenn der anteil deutlich
steigen würde würde man sagen ja jetzt
wird es wieder bedrohlich ja jetzt sehen
wir ein anstieg das ist gerade nicht so
das liegt auch daran dass wir zum
beispiel flächendeckend reiserückkehrer
getestet haben auch es zum teil auch aus
nicht- risikogebieten das heißt nur weil
die infektionszahlen steigen heisst das
nicht dass man gleich in diesen alarm
modus verfallen sollte über den alarm
modus hat auch jens spahn gestern
gesprochen auch da wollen wir noch
einmal reinschauen aus unserem talk die
richtigen fragen
wir sind bis hierhin gut durchgekommen
die lage heute ist eine gute weil es
unter kontrolle ist stand heute
und gleichzeitig müssen wir einfach
aufpassen dass wir nicht in so eine
dynamik rein kommen wie wir sie in
spanien sehen für mich ist dass ich wenn
ich mit meinem spanischen kollegen
telefoniere regelmäßig denn dann finde
ich das schon fast tragisch es gibt kaum
ein land in europa das mit härteren
maßnahmen ich habe gerade schon mal
gesagt militär auf der straße
passierscheine familien über wochen
maximal eine halbe stunde stunde raus
durften aus ihren wohnungen kaum ein
land das mit härteren maßnahmen dieses
virus unter kontrolle gebracht hat die
dynamik und wo ist jetzt auf einmal so
entglitten ist und das möchte ich
einfach für deutschland vermeiden ich
möchte dass wir ein realistisches bild
haben dass wir miteinander wachsam sind
aber eben auch nicht im alarm modus die
ganze zeit wenn jeden tag alarm ist es
irgendwann gar keinen alarm mehr sondern
dass wir einfach mit der nötigen
aufmerksamkeit ernsthaftigkeit aber auch
zuversicht mit dem was wir schon
geschafft haben bin ich zuversichtlich
wenn wir miteinander um beieinander
bleibt mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren